it's been a while since I last played
roller coaster [ __ ] and I really need to
do this right now because I just have
the urge to play this game which
probably has to do with the fact that
we're playing time at heights today and
this park is just the supportassist
amazing hold on i have a blade runner
goes i get through in a way so excuse me
if I just completely suck at pretty much
everything I try to do in this game I
just want to I just want to get this
real quick out of there that this park
is one of the reasons why I think that
roller coaster kun one is the best game
ever made it's just it's the first box
you have just kind of simple just a very
small build up of you know getting more
attractions and making the levels harder
but at this point you actually get a
full-grown Pike that is just amazing
like both in the sense that having this
the slight build up of the increasing
you know overall I don't know it's it's
it's just the Pikes get more it's so
hard to explain it basically frontier
the m the what is it called again and
then I forest frontiers it's just empty
and easy and this is the part where the
game actually gets harder and harder I
actually see some advanced designs and
in that sense the game is just all so
amazing since this Marcus's so well
designed though I don't care really too
much for this right it is just this egg
or arachnophobia of course is a pretty
cool but it's all about agoraphobia and
claustrophobia obviously amazing
coasters and this one's just kind of
their butts I suppose it's every Park
neater woody isn't it pretty important
and yeah that's just all so this is like
the signature pork of the game if you've
ever played it in your childhood this is
probably the park you'll remember you
you'll probably forget like gentle Glen
and haunted harbour butts diamond
heights is this something that stays
with you for the rest of your life
that's enough nostalgia banter i would
say since there's actually some stuff to
fix I don't know if to handyman will do
the job actually I don't know how much
money am I actually making plenty of
money to keep the paths just slightly
more clean and one of the thing that one
of the things that doesn't only about
this bike is you know having those
lights and they always get like
vandalized and stuff but then again I
didn't think I really care about that
too much I don't care about that enough
to remove on the lights right now see
there's already problems with like
people are puking all over the pike I
need to set some areas for these guys
you're gonna walk right over here
actually this is not like the most
important area but before people puke
when they write roller coaster one also
that's likely one mistake this thing is
called roller coaster one it's no sense
um right and this is this guy is gonna
be like a regular phobia guy actually no
this is a claustrophobia and stuff you
probably want to have him just around
this exit area since my god do people
puke after running this right but i do
want to cover the entire park with this
i can always add in more handyman at a
later stage when i earn more money but
right now my my main objective is just
to get three handyman and all three in
like the main coastal areas well i
forgot about the Snake River Falls it's
not the name I seriously haven't played
this park in there quite a while so I
don't exactly if that is the name but
this right Snake River Falls there we go
and yeah we kind of do want to have a
handyman or for that like I don't really
see how people need to puke after a year
after a log flume but to each their own
i suppose and we don't want to leave a
single part of this park and walked on
by our handyman right here and it's also
time to fix this point in a sense that's
um yeah there isn't really anything in
terms of stalls I think also we're
renaming this thing what is this I've no
good name for this so this is just gonna
whoa don't don't do that don't be that
guy who has like caps on so yeah that's
all good but yeah that's not even though
it's not even a freaking toilet in this
bike
this park is supposed to be that really
good park that you see is a play and
then you're like wow there's actually
some massive there's actually a lot of
things that you can do in this game and
at that point you also kind of just lose
your own dignity thinking that oh my god
I've just been making terrible parks and
this is what the creators of the game
came up with just a central bathroom
bathroom one is this is a good name
don't really care and keep only to eat
we don't have any drinks no no the the
okay we're researching a shop / store
and I I really haven't played this point
nor the game in a very long time but I
would assume since we already have the
information and we have some food and we
have toilets that the next thing is
going to be drinks so I'm just going to
turn all that off we don't need
improvements we don't need any of that
stuff what do we have for plenty of
gentle rides honestly we already have a
couple of those but we don't have the
pirate ship yet I'm gonna say I should
invest in thrill rides and
rollercoasters because we do need
another roller coaster I don't know what
that what's the first thing like you can
wooden coaster inverted B&M coaster I
don't know what else there was honestly
maybe like to get a spinning coaster in
this park at some point in time those
things are always cool when Moloch Oh
stickin one in any case pirate ship
because we do need like that like gentle
thrill the only problem with this park
is yeah a disc it is really hard to
actually fit anything into this bike how
much money have I been spending I've
actually in there gaining money I
suppose that's good quite a lot actually
yeah I need to find a place with this
baby right here um this is this is on a
hill so it's not like this is going to
really do too much I don't know
no that's not going to look good it is
always so hard to find a good place for
this thing to find a good place about
anything in this bike since it's already
like kind of fall except for this area
but that is so hard to fit anything into
so yeah why do I want to put this thing
so that it's not like overcrowded but
that it doesn't look awkward either when
I keep all this flat area reserved for
other rides and rollercoasters this by
the way is the best angle to view this
thing from it's just beautiful how many
plague does those little dips and then
it comes out with its own I don't know
it just love that if that's my lost
algae or not I have no idea but it's so
cool I'm doing it aside for a place for
this thing anyway you know looking at it
to be very honest I don't think that
this place is going to be too useful for
anything but it's too big for a pirate
ship like I could put am a witch things
like a twisting egg egg scrambler thing
right over there at some later stage so
I might want to reconsider placing it
there I was thinking that you know I
could place it over here on top of the
hill that would be kind of cool but then
and again it would be a really be the
most practical thing ever you know I
should probably just do that I probably
should yeah am I going for that
it's not like I can really fit it in
anywhere else too well then I do need to
consider that though hold on a second
when I use this space with something you
know I should be able to I'm just gonna
I'm just going to terraform this land
and see if I can do something with that
rid of that performance something like
that no idea exactly how this is going
to work but I wouldn't have it somewhere
in this area oh there's a tree in the
way and always have to terraform the
wrong spot that goes all my money wasted
on terrible terraforming I'm very sorry
this is my ICT life and oj all right
that's not enough space hmm have it over
there though now it's probably yeah it's
probably just better to lower this thing
too there we go that's one thing that
has kind of annoyed me like if you
delete a corner of a piece it costs you
the same amount of money as deleting the
I mean as terraforming the entire thing
which I know you stupid and I'm gonna
have to move this part otherwise it's
going to look quite ugly and people are
gonna get lost which they will do
regardless come on idiots what are you
doing I'm hungry oh good point I forgot
to place anything for that let me do
that right away after i'm done with this
this is not the best way to deal with
this mm-hmm then again what is a better
way yeah okay I'm not going to make any
terrible bridges because making bridges
with paths it's just like it's like
cheating with path works we don't do
that no I'm just gonna add some
terraforming tricks over here maybe I
can place like some hedges or something
I know something funky and this can all
be removed well not not all of it since
I do want to keep that elevated there we
go something like that it's not really
the best solution to this problem but I
think it is the best looking solution
and arguably the most realistic given
the terrain
so yeah let's open this thing a swinging
ship I've already named 1l storm and
I've got like another thing so um yeah
what should I go for hey um yeah I don't
know this is a this is so hard I so suck
at names I shouldn't be I shouldn't even
be spending time in this like for real
which is gonna come up with like some
stupid thing like Blackbeard's fun boats
yeah that's that's the name beautiful
how much money am I going to ask for
this 230 that is quite a lot of money
for a few few spins on the ship but
whatever pupil whatever people feel like
doing and makes me money is alright with
me and I'd like to have a hedge over
here there's a little there's not a lot
of light green color in this and a
likely light green color so here we go
that is something our decorate I'll do
more decorations at a later stage but
right now I need to get some food I
desperately need to get some food it's
not really an area where you can add a
food court in any way nope so um yeah
why do I place my food court in this
pike it's just such a lack of space
um-hmm yeah that's actually kind of
tough what do I even tell me what do I
even do over here suppose I can turn
this into a food court with some fries
fries I'm just going to call that fries
no this is going to be a this is going
to be what's that called again this is a
this is going to be wendys actually that
makes a lot of sense you can just take
them take them fast food chains I don't
have to come up with anything really but
it kind of does fit and using this
terrain I can get a tiny bit of that in
she looks completely terrible you know
what [ __ ] that that is not going to
happen I'll just like this is not a good
idea since people will get most but it
looks better so ok I'm gonna just go for
like the double bench action over here
benches over there which is over there
and litter bins litter bins about that
area and we should be fine so i would
like to i would like to add some like
different stuff too that's doesn't
really look too cool when it's little
just stoned actually that looks better
[ __ ] it there we go um ok so what am i
getting over here last development was a
drink store perfects there we go fries
and drinks over here and it's gonna be
the Pepsi's yeah definitely there we go
and that's all right there's not even
anything else I think I can actually
feel the right now now this is your
haunted house but nobody likes the
haunted house suppose that's like the
one issue with this point is that pretty
much already filled to the brim with
attractions so I'm gonna move I'm gonna
have to move to this area as soon as I
can actually build some good rides on
that I slip had a really cool wooden
roller coaster over here and they call
inverts on this island I mean it's not
really an islands on this peninsula
thing image neither than my island is
this weird here basically and that was
actually really cool but no we do want
something else right now suppose I can
do some decoration work and yes I'm
overusing the edges together edges are
just oh my god that's so amazing
over here since there's not really any
fence of any sorts just want to add like
a fence on the side I can't add it there
but can add it there oh well then
doesn't really matter too much like
anybody's really going to see that and
lands on top of the hill and then I can
add some Decker decoration ish trees to
that also i would say maximum funding I
can't wait this street is a kind of cool
yeah you can't do that any problem with
that is that this land is not really all
that great doesn't matter it just keep
going it's all right you know what I
wanna might want to replay some of those
parts mostly how does this look doesn't
that just look tons better I know it has
a ring to it I'm gonna try that those
are removed like the litter bins and
benches and stuff so I'll have to
replace those pretty soon but I just
find that for a hilly areas something
like this just fits so much better than
the standard park I know this is pretty
much wasted money at this point but uh
it looks cool ok so that's that now
there were a couple of benches on top of
that area right there and some there and
some litter bins and there is puke all
over this area so that is not good I
thought I aside this guy to this area
but where did not his sign this guy to
others guy has no oh well I think I
aside this guy took both those areas as
a terrible mistake that's not gonna
happen you're not going to be on both
those areas that's not good you're going
to walk on way too many places at once
this guy is going to be around
arachnophobia there we go
that should be a lot better we don't get
guys just running in the middle of
nowhere and it starts raining just
gorgeous I'm like getting anything yet
through all right that's probably the X
scrambler honestly I let your scrambled
eggs I'm sorry and yeah I would like to
keep the asphalt parts like on the
bridges because that sir that's pretty
alright is there anywhere else where I
can like at different parts though don't
think that's going to quite work just
yet but again yeah I'll just do that
later also I'm gonna I'm gonna have
another handy man that I can like just
move around the pike to make sure that I
can clean up as much as I can since it
is turning into a mess right here also I
didn't even check the prices yet I see I
am such an idiot one playing playing
roller coast a goon I just forget pretty
much everything I have to do so last
time I always forget to open my freaking
toilets it yeah everything is open so at
least I didn't forget to open the toilet
to this time okay so this thing so much
better actually no I am a bigger know
which one is my favorite actually I
don't think I really have a favorite I
think when I was younger I always liked
claustrophobia the most since I just
found it intriguing how it went through
all those tunnels but then when you turn
on underground view it just looks so
lame underground so you know they're
both cool they don't they don't work
well without each other so you can't
just pick one um so yeah this might by
the way is way too intense for a junior
ride 570 yeah and how much can I ask for
fries no idea but 150 seems like a fair
price and how many boats does this thing
has just nine see that's the problem
with Snake River Falls it is just so
inefficient pretty slow and it doesn't
really have many boats and
um yeah it's pretty weird with its drops
and all that but alright it makes money
so that's cool and how much can I ask
for this thing again I'm asking it's way
too much okay and nobody likes the
railroad is this thing even make it a
thousand an hour that's a lot all right
then there we go and I think that's
almost it we can probably still ask some
money for this thing does this thing
have unlimited rise for admission it is
not going down like thats all you need
to close it before you can do that but
yeah this is it this is an issue because
this is a pretty long queue right now
and that is not cool I don't know what
people are thinking I want to get off
short stuff slide if you have unlimited
a give unlimited amount of sliced man
you can just you can just get off
whatever you want see this is this is
not good I'm going to close that thing
change the settings of that single ride
permission and open it Mike's people on
the right should always be five and it's
awaiting test results yeah those test
results are still bit shaky especially
on the right like this but whatever
floats you go dude is it time for some
see that was the scrambled eggs so it
almost say it all makes sense honestly
but does this thing have any test
results yet i contest that thing of
course you can't test it but you still
need to wait the test results that is
flawless roller coaster can three logic
and we do get these scrambled eggs so i
think that this would be the best place
for matts after I terraform that tiny
bit
there we go and this can just stay the
way it is oops that's too big actually
was probably a better idea to use the
other thing well whatever and scrambled
eggs over here why would you I want to
have it in this area you know in all
honesty this this might actually be a
better area for the haunted house even
though now actually no no nope nope you
know you would like to place that thing
in like the middle of the forest
something like that so thing is I feel
like if I built just a scrambled eggs
over here I would be wasting the
possible flat right space but then again
you don't really get as many flat rides
in this bike as you would think with its
terraforming in a lot so I'm just gonna
do something similar to the whoops that
goes all my money there's something
similar to the this thing grumbles
gallopers and build something like that
there we go money's actually like the
only thing you don't have to worry about
in this bike like that's the only issue
it is still a bit easy granted rights
like to break down in this park and
you'll like a pug likes to like get a
lot of vandalism stuff going on but
still it is a pretty usually park
getting all that money and stuff so
there we go scrambled eggs it's open Utz
and change the color scheme I thing like
the blue color scheme with me slightly
better over here since I don't really
have too much blue in the park yet in
any case that looks pretty cool and I
would like to have some different trees
in the pike it's kind of boring when it
comes to that so far never row of these
things yeah that's pretty good if
there's not enough trees in the tail not
on a large variety in any case so that's
pretty cool and on this side of the hill
and also liked have some trees but like
slightly different trees stuff like that
and that looks all right
okay hold on a second benches also might
want to change the path over here
honestly what would be better over here
like a brown pot let's try it out
actually doesn't look that bad I can
have that more often in the bike to need
to get some of these so far I haven't
really seen any case of vandalism but
seeing the amount of money that i'm
earning oh my god I forgot to I forgot
to set it to not mow the grass I'll just
get a higher new handyman I have two
random handyman that can just do
whatever you are not going to mow the
grass there sue and I'll just get a
security guard just get just to possibly
prevent some vandalism in the future how
much money am I earning a month like I
might actually want to even get another
one um ride tickets that's 3,000 us so
much like how much does this guy cost
even 45 a month yeah I can have plenty
of that it doesn't really matter so
security guides click i am going to
assign these two different places in the
pike but i'm gonna skip that part since
there's not really any lamps or anything
like that it's many of the lamps and the
benches that I'm worried about
especially the benches in the eating
areas since you don't want those to be
vandalized and this guy is going to work
right here yeah like this entire thing
basically and this guy is going to guard
the entrance area of the pike yes you
are and oh my that has loads of people
sitting cover that I didn't even account
for that I don't have enough benches to
let all those people sit where they want
to sit so I'm gonna add some benches
over here there you go there's also lots
of litter over there so yeah where's my
random secure with higher new handyman
pocket they don't even cause that much
as 35 a month and i'm earning plenty of
money anyway okay so that is all good
and well we get another thrill ride
which
it's cool and all but I would have some
real roller coasters at this point
claustrophobia has broken down oh
speaking of that I should house some
mechanics I don't know what these guys
walking patterns on what is your walking
pattern yeah okay one side of the pike
another guy has the other side of the
park most likely actually doesn't look
like that no that guy just has that area
you know that's a shitty idea that's a
really shitty idea that I'm going to get
rid of hopefully you are not going to
work right here since I'm gonna get
another handyman for that because
claustrophobia and agoraphobia always
crush speaking of which claustrophobia
is going to crash at some point in time
the the brake failure and claustrophobia
is something you can't avoid that's like
final destination [ __ ] you wonder if you
don't want to have a brake failure at
claustrophobia better cheat death or
something like that who's who is the
mechanic who was supposed to only got
that area now I they're both just
conning that area no all right that is
not good I was this guy all rights I was
looking at the wrong guy presumably yeah
this guy has to do that area this guy
does know area so this guy is going to
do the in-between area including
claustrophobia and agoraphobia so that
should be fine it is time to keep death
actually something which I've forgotten
to do so far and get rid of one of the
trains on the claustrophobia yeah it's
sad to see it go but I really need to
like replace the strain as soon as this
thing is repaired [ __ ] hell so yeah
like at some point in time even in the
first year I think you have a pretty big
chance that that thing's going to crush
kill some people and kill your rap too
in the process and I don't want to do
that so yeah no more synchronization
action for claustrophobia at this point
but I need this thing to not crush plus
it's not even making that much money
agoraphobia is making much more anyway
though that might have to do with the
fact that it's not broken get rid of
these things and get the water slide
excellent the water slide is the one
thing that nobody likes it you know
given me what it's like does look pretty
cool it is just a ride that's pretty
high-tech they make it work and look
good but we do get it so I might as well
do something with it I really don't know
I feel like this time it would actually
be a surprisingly good area to build
able to slide in um granted it would
become really like densely built over
here but then again hey what's a slight
would be pretty cool so um yeah I don't
know what to do with us but it's this
thing repaired there we go it is
repaired time to get rid of that one
train prevents death from happening and
we're good to go at this one I don't
think yeah I agoraphobia doesn't hit the
station brakes with too much speed so
that should be completely fine so I'm
we're safe for now at least until
something else is going to crash no i
don't i don't think anything on this
bike really crushes too bad this thing
certainly doesn't so we should have no
fatal accidents don't quote me on that
one but from what i remember this is
completely safe so yeah they can't find
the bathrooms on my bike okay that's the
last thing i'll do that today won't is
my current bathroom back up right over
there and we don't have anything on this
side of the Pikes oh yeah right you do
have a good argument right there
actually might want to have three
bathrooms like I have room for another
bathroom over here or over there that's
actually better bothering to and near
the entrance i'm going to get my first
bathroom especially considering how sick
people get from snake river falls so
there's going to be a bathroom over here
to there we go so i think that should do
as a first episode thank you guys so
much for watching hold on i need to save
this game before I lose it diamond
heights and
I'll see you all next time I guess so
see you space cowboys